master Wayne there are imaging is  showing me two dozen hostiles on the  third floor why don't I drop you off on  the second  I'm getting slow in my old age effort  you've new got too old to die young not  for lack of trying  he has the power to wipe out the entire  human race as we believe there's even a  1% chance that he is our enemy we have  to take it as an absolute sir  greatest gladiator match in the history  of the world God versus man  day versus night you psychotic it's a  three syllable word for any thought too  big for little minds  but now if you wouldn't like you I don't  think you've ever known a woman like me  why in America  but power can be innocent  in the universe human beings have a  horrible track record of following  people with great power perhaps an  absolute power corrupts absolutely chaos